es la peor crisis desde 2014
las explosiones no cesan el ejército
israelí bombardea la franja de gaza
donde ha matado a decenas de civiles y a
líderes de hamás este grupo responde con
cohetes y también deja víctimas mortales
en israel según el ejército israelí
desde la franja de gaza se han enviado
1.600 cohetes muchos de ellos han sido
interceptados por la defensa antimisiles
de israel
hay momentos terroríficos por ejemplo
cuando vi salir a un padre con sus hijos
de un apartamento oscuro como una
linterna en la cabeza porque un misil
impactó en una casa encima de la suya es
terrible
y dejó la víctima mente sé cómo queda
una escalada entre dos fuerzas
desiguales en gaza- las limitaciones a
la circulación y a los servicios básicos
impuestas por israel son la norma para
los palestinos human right watch acusó a
tel aviv por el apartheid que ejerce
sobre la población palestina el
escenario en gaza es el de edificios
pulverizados como la torre al shurouq
que albergaba una cadena de televisión
creada por hamás el ejército de israel
también asaltó una oficina de
inteligencia de la organización
islamista de noche en el hospital las
ambulancias no paran de llegar estaba
delante de una tienda y de repente un
misil cayó sobre nosotros no a todos
personas el causó ocho heridos
estaba sentado dentro de la tienda y
otros estaban en la casa cuando vimos el
estruendo de los bombardeos después
perdí el conocimiento no me acuerdo de
nada
las tensiones pueden aumentar israel
anunció el despliegue masivo de fuerzas
militares y jamás se declara listo para
resistir